the election analyst and partner at ham
brie strategy james kanack asourian
thank you very much for being with us I
mean people always say that it's
policies that matter to them but just
personality actually matter as well I
think personality and how people think
leaders are credible are is the key
reason behind election results I mean
there's been a lot of election surprises
over the last four or five years
2015-2017 was a surprise and 2016
obviously was but a large amount of what
explains the result of 2015 and 2017
were effectively the favorability and
leadership ratings of Theresa May and
Jeremy Corbyn in 2017 and believe that
David Cameron had over Ed Miliband in
2015 interesting stuff and we can have a
little look now at the current state of
the parties and this is the Sky News new
gov display the most recent state state
of voting intention you can see there
the Conservatives on 42 laid 130 the Lib
Dems on 15 and then the others really
kind of languishing I guess around four
it hasn't moved that much this whole
campaign has and I know you've worked on
election companies well haven't you been
what we've read a bizarre example the
Conservative Party and do you see this
changing I think there's a couple of
things first of all for the first couple
of weeks of the campaign the polling has
been quite stable there's been broadly a
couple of trends the first is a
consolidation towards the two main party
so that's the Conservatives and labor so
that's gone up it's very similar to the
2017 Lib Dems falling away flatly yes
exactly and the Greens less so but
certainly the brexit party for a number
of reasons is down from double-digit
since the beginning of the campaign and
I think the second interesting thing
from from this regard is we the Labour
vote I think though has not continued
its rise as it in 2017 so we still have
a green vote of 4% that's double the
vote that the Greens got in 2017 it's a
very material vote that's worth thinking
about and then the Liberal Democrats
seem to have plateaued at 15% obviously
down from 20's or mid-twenties that they
were around a month ago I mean broadly
Sophie did this this result here which i
think is pretty good points are very
clear conservative majority if this is
what happened in an election today
is largely a result of which of the two
main parties can retain their 2017
voucher better the Sky News you go
polling that you've done I think some of
the data underlying it is very
interesting so for this graph for
example we know from the data that 85%
of 2017 conservative voters intend to do
so again but the same figure for the
Labour Party is 65 percent Wow so
they're going perhaps the Lib Dems maybe
a few more to the Green Party exactly
it's kind of going everywhere in fact
also the Conservatives there's a there's
an asymmetry here which is that roughly
10% of the people that voted labour last
time intend to vote conservative this
time put the figure the other way so
Tories who are going to vote labour is
only 2% and I think that asymmetry is
explaining this result at a 12 point gap
and let's have a look shall we at some
of the kind of personality polling that
would be doing if you like and we asked
people who would make the best Prime
Minister for tea said Boris Johnson 16
Jeremy Corbyn 14 Jay Swinson firstly
does this question matter yes it does
matter I mean the the personality
whether that's measuring credibility or
whether people like the candidate are
both important factors in an election
outcome I mean broadly this is this is
very bad news for the Labour Party in
Jeremy Corbyn these are not the kind of
figures that you would hope to go into
in an election result that produces a
Labour government they are actually
quite different to the results in the
2017 election where the personal ratings
of Jeremy Corbyn and the personal
ratings of Theresa may actually met
somewhere in the middle and is that
because people didn't like to reason a
very much because people's view on
Jeremy Corbyn has changed I think
actually in the 2017 election the the
gap was closed almost entirely result of
people liking Jeremy Corbyn gets him to
know him and understanding his policies
what he stood for his values like the
manifesto that he was putting forward
exactly and all those coalesced to
produce kind of favorability ratings for
Corbin in 2017 that were very strong
it's quite hard to reinflates balloon
it's not great jokes when snyder there
was it and really it's interesting cuz
it feels like the Lib Dems have put her
at the centre of their campaign and it's
her face on the bass that's her date on
the look on the leaflets I mean looking
at this was that a mistake
yes it's very interesting the difference
in the Labour campaign and the Liberal
Democrat campaign so the Labour Party
know and understand jeremy corbyn's
leadership ratings but they also
understand that a lot of the underlying
policies and corbin omics actually quite
popular and therefore their campaign is
very much a triangulation between the
two the decision to make the Liberal
Democrat campaign presidential is I
think was probably unfounded in terms of
the data there's no evidence that Joe
Swinton was particularly popular in fact
people don't really know her before this
campaign that's precisely right and as
I've got to know her she's become less
popular so I think if you track her
favorability over time the number of
people that like her at the beginning of
the campaign is the same as it is now
but broadly the number of people that
don't like cares almost doubles let's
have a look at some those favorability
ratings shall we and this is the five
leaders you've got Boris Johnson there
Jeremy Corbyn Joe Swenson Nigel frosh
and Nicola Sturgeon and this is like
kind of balance between people who have
a favorable opinion and have an
unfavorable opinion I mean no one does
brilliantly here do they I mean I guess
for a strong sense it is not too bad and
also Nicola Sturgeon as well I wish to
point out that this is specifically
voters in Scotland which is where she's
of course outstanding with the SNP I
mean the the main thing to note here is
is yes Britain is Britain is is in an
ambiguous place in regards to how it how
it likes its leaders and but I think the
main thing to know about this graph and
favorability data and leadership data is
the gap between the Prime Minister and
the leader of the Opposition that is
absolutely what drives the final outcome
of an election because ninety percent of
seats are conservative labour seats at
2017 in terms of the challenges here
these negative ratings for Corbin I
think very much back up the double-digit
lead that exists in the polls there's a
very linear and straight line
relationship between these types of
results the Joe Swinson figures are
interesting in that at the beginning of
the campaign her unfavorables were close
to 30 in the 30s and effectively that's
just grown over time so we talk about
people having good or bad campaigns and
actually you'd have to say the people
who've had the worst campaign are the
Liberal Democrats at this stage I also
think Nigel Farage's ratings are very
interesting when people call him a
Marmite politician
this is exactly what we're talking about
first of all more people like Nigel
Faraj than Jeremy Corbyn and Joe Swinson
I think that's just a fact worth
dwelling on when we talk about Nigel
Farraj as being a fringe politician and
here we are pointing him as the second
most popular leader in the UK but on the
other hand his negatives are enormous
and in this sense he is very much a as
it were a right-wing or you know to the
far right of that version of Jeremy
Corbyn interesting stuff and then just
finally we asked people about the
standard of leadership that they're
seeing at the minute from the leaders
compared to leaders in the past we asked
how do you write the standard of
leadership shown by the party leaders
compared to leaders in previous general
elections look away now by the way if
you are a party leader you do not want
to have a look at this graph let's have
a quick look I hope you do we should be
are trying to make that now go go so
only five percent think they're better
45 percent think they're worse 30
percent saying 20 percent don't know I
mean it's not great is it no but I think
with questions like this you do have to
be careful I think there's very much a
case of Rose tinted glasses I mean if
you look at polling now in terms of how
people view Gordon Brown and John Major
actually it's not too bad for them even
though both of them were kicked out of
government and lost 50 to 100 seats so I
think there's an element of which we
think things that are proximate to us
are worse and things that are in the
past up are better I would have to say
these these underlying figures are not
great both for the the political leaders
and and and I guess the country and
democracy and it's very interesting that
there's there's a lot of difference by
party voting for these figures so
fundamentally the people who are most
disillusioned with British politics and
believe that the party leaders are worse
this time offer double Democrats so I
think that 45% worse figure is
approaching 70 percent for them at the
same time I mean I do a lot of going out
onto high streets and talking to people
in different pass the country and it is
extraordinary I think that the amount of
concern people have towards all of the
party leaders and I know that there is a
general underlying thing in the past
where people don't like politicians they
don't trust them but it does feel at the
minute to be particularly pronounced and
these are people who are engage with
politics as well they're not completely
switched off I think it matters they're
just concerned about the choice they've
got in front of them
there's there's definitely an element of
people not entirely being happy with the
options that are being presented in
front of them for example in one of the
first slides you showed on preferred
prime minister we had one and four
people who literally couldn't make a
choice when they were presented with the
three people well three people and two
of whom could credibly be Prime Minister
so that's clearly not a great place for
the country to be in and yes I'm in this
election even though the options may not
be palatable to a number of people a lot
of people will be voting with their
noses held I don't think that means that
there's a lack of engagement I mean in
2017 for example Theresa May had very
very small positive ratings and Jeremy
Corbyn had negative ratings but we saw
turnout go up to 72 percent and we saw
the two-party vote share exceed 80
percent so there's not really a linear
relationship between how people feel and
whether they like the leaders that are
presented in front of them and then how
engaged they are in the election
interesting stuff thanks so much coming
on the show and for talking us through
that analysis we'd be doing thank you
James thank you